[Music]
so
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome to
let's talk to tony michael's podcast
we have a great interview for you today
big big stuff gonna happen
we have gabe with us at the top
at the very top
we have gabe
doing his thing over here playing the
drums he likes he likes the rock music
over here he likes the rock music
how are you how are you gabe
good let's get this show [ __ ] get
started dude that's that's what i'm
saying so tell us about this interview
you've been excited about it
yeah okay so
this interview we dive into uh the the
leaked data that came from the gifts and
go hacks
uh we get some analysis from high
fidelity from radicalized podcast
uh he gives us an inside look he he
basically
it's all suspect it's all sketchy as
[ __ ]
you know money laundering fraudulent
things like we really dive into it uh
and yeah it's no one's really covered
this so it's it's great that we're able
to get this uh
we got someone else joining us uh brett
manziel who's joining us
who's on the show who's there who's
coming on how are you how are you sir
i'm good guys so i've been hearing about
this episode that's coming up and i
could not be more excited for it
i hear you guys are about to drop
some really really big news
there's a there's a lot of stuff going
on in this interview um not just not
just in the data that comes out but like
the suspicion behind it and then like
where it comes from and some of the
names that are connected in this stuff
and really like
it
the the thing that got me the most is
like this seems like a trial run like a
practice run yeah don't you think gabe
yeah yeah i would it's they're
definitely uh
doing a bit of a uh as you said a trial
they're
testing one market before they would go
into another market to see if it was
successful
um obviously we know that the trucker
convoy that uh
you know headed to dc was pretty uh
lackluster it was like a tumble the
worst week
yeah it was yeah
the whole argument is null because they
[ __ ] lifted the mandates across the
entire country like right not even in
los angeles like you don't have to wear
a mask and doors anymore like exactly
well i was like the last holdout so
they're doing this convoy and then
they're also complaining about gas
prices but driving your big truck across
the country and complaining about gas
prices it seems a little hypocritical
you're spending a lot of money to do
that right and then in the midst of like
the precipice of world war three when
you see the most heroic the bravest
people on the planet literally driving
into harm's way to fight a war against
an invader who is literally threatening
democracy
itself and their very freedom well
you're like i'm getting my trucking on
my masks
i had to wear a mask for a few weeks
the best part the best part was the
because i i tweeted it it went over like
a wet fart and a white thong because the
best part is they had that rally and
there was like one one person on stage
and maybe three or four people watching
there were more reporters yeah and then
there were actual protests
i gave did you post the the clip of the
round oh my god i was like one dude on
stage and just this sea of emptiness
which is i i mean i'm happy to see that
hopefully these movements are are dying
out but it's funny like this story while
it's a massive story that you guys are
about to break here on this podcast it's
also kind of funny because like it's one
of those things where it's like of
course like
of course it was it's like when we heard
about this eastman you know this new
eastman news coming out and the january
six committees like donald trump may
have committed a crime on january 6.
you're like bombshell story yes but
water is water right right of course of
course of course it is we have a lot of
we have uh brett and
caitlin says hi let's go
carter says good morning minus lisa says
hi to everyone debbie says hi we've got
all these uh midas robin says hi to
brett
a lot of people
we got a lot of people with us so good
morning to everybody we're glad you made
it for this interview because it's going
to be big we got some other news too
right brett
yeah well which uh which which is we're
talking about i don't i don't see i
don't i don't be spoiler i don't want to
play the wrong news so well you know you
don't get hinted at me because i don't
want to spoil the wrong belt well uh we
partnered with you guys on a couple
other interviews including this one and
uh i think i think uh starting next week
we're going to be uh possibly with the
midas media network is that correct
wait a second what
is this true i i hear i hear i don't
know if you talk to the students jordy
jordan on one show get out of here who
approved this
jordan
jordy jordy said that he made the
decision i know i know he's the one
right i don't think that's how this
organization works you know i i don't
know i i he he's not allowed to have
passwords but i know he's allowed to
make these big decisions so no it's true
it's true i'm i'm joking around it's all
very true so uh this is a sneak preview
also we were gonna tease it on our show
and be like oh i'm sorry we got an
announcement coming next week but
but i'll say it now for the listeners
who are here and then more people will
find out later that beginning next week
we're gonna move i mean nothing is going
to move so i don't want to phrase it
like that the tony michaels podcast is
going to be in the same place you get it
now you're going to be able to watch it
the same place that you're watching
right now but we're going to bring it on
the midas touch media network the midas
media network so we're going to put our
promotional arm behind it we love this
show so much we watch all the time and
we just love what you're building here
and we'd love to bring it in in the
family and uh and make it one of the
biggest morning shows out there i mean
what you're doing is special and it
doesn't really exist
you know i i i would say on the left but
in this pro-democracy space right now
the battle that we're in like it's it's
straight up you are like the one person
who has broken through in the space so
we want to make this as big as possible
and it's going to be great to have you
guys on the mida speedy now well and we
we appreciate all the partnership we've
had in the past you guys have been on
the show and hopefully we can have you
guys and all all the all the characters
and all the all the partners uh there at
the midas media network come on the show
and and give us their insight as their
as their content drops and stuff too so
you have to forgive my voice i'm a
little i'm a little weak tony got a
little too excited this morning he was
like damned good thing good thing i
don't have to talk a lot today because
we have this interview coming so brett
we we appreciate you joining us and
we're going to get to the interview
thanks a lot buddy for um for helping us
with the distribution of this i know
everyone's gonna like it and there's
probably some articles and stuff coming
out too maybe that's another piece of
news that uh that will happen oh yeah
yeah for now you know keep keep on
crushing it you guys um everybody if
you're a new viewer right now i know we
got a lot of viewers right now on
twitter that i'm seeing if you're a new
viewer go ahead and subscribe to the
tony michaels podcast and head on over
to their youtube channel as well make
sure you're subscribed to the channel um
a lot of fun interactions with followers
and fans and everything and it's a great
way to start your morning every morning
so
oh look at these girls the other thing
the other thing the other thing these
are great the other great part about
about subscribing is every once in a
while gabe comes on in a wig and like he
surprises the [ __ ] out of me i don't
even know he's gonna do it yeah you know
who knows he comes running away you see
look he's got he's got glad all ready to
go
all right guys thank you hey thanks a
lot brad we'll talk to you soon have a
great show i'll catch you guys soon
we'll see you later
so um a big big announcements big
announcements um
hopefully we'll have more announcements
today on the twitter account as some of
that other news drops if we have those
articles out there um we'll see how that
that all plays out and works um i know i
know you you're you're wanting to you're
itching to get get some of that out
there so yeah well you know a lot of a
lot of work in the background you know
yes mm-hmm yeah seeing people in there
and this this this is an interview that
that is going to take the whole show so
everyone hang tight um
this interviews with high fidelity at
radicalized podcast um we had heidi kuda
on who is one of his co-hosts um with
radicalized podcasts so go over go over
to their twitter account as well and
follow them um
you can't file a high fidelity on on
twitter though right right yeah yeah he
he mentions it in uh in the interview of
why
uh
yep well you know maybe maybe just maybe
he'll get his back and then jim
stewartson also i think he's still still
suspended but yeah profile heidi go file
the podcast over on twitter uh go to
their youtube channel um they do a
podcast every week as well
so check them out um again we've had
heidi on before great guest um and heidi
if you're listening we hope to have you
back uh soon yeah we like we like you
know high fidelity is good but you know
heidi you know she's much easier to talk
to no i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding um so so everyone hang
tight right after the break right after
this break you'll see the the interview
with high fidelity about the ottawa
trucker data leak and is it a virtual
washing machine or not i think that's
going to be the big question so hang
tight we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back from the break we
have a special guest for you here today
and he's got some information he'd like
to share with us
our guest is hi fidelity the co-host of
the radicalized podcast on youtube and
long time it nerd he says long time i've
i've been doing i.t for 22 years okay
i've been yeah so it's been a couple
decades that you've been an i.t nerd is
what you're saying yeah well good well i
hope i hope the information that you
have and the questions that i have about
it i know gabe's got a lot of questions
i've got a lot of questions too about
this information that you that you've
been scouring through uh but tell us a
little bit about yourself first and then
and then we'll get to this information
how you come across it and what you're
finding in it a little bit about myself
so uh i have done everything in it from
a desktop support guy
to database administration
to
security to
designing systems for multinational
companies that span across the globe
like uh you know
i can't say exactly who but i had some
clients up in detroit they make stuff
out of metal and rubber and i helped
design systems for them i guess who they
are but
i designed systems for them that
actually you know like china to
california to detroit to new york to
europe to just
non-important things yeah right yeah
yeah just little stuff right right right
so so what is this what is this this
information that you want to share with
us and and where did you get it why is
it significant um and then we'll get
into it
of the information itself and we'll ask
some questions but tell us for a little
bit of background of what this
information is how how it came to be
that you got your hands on it uh so the
information i got was uh
you know the freedom convoy 2022
fundraiser on gibson go
uh
that data was leaked as a matter of fact
gibson go has had i think we're on our
fourth leak now they had a leak about
the written house data okay which is
sick which is significant right to this
very very significant okay um
and actually that's how i got into this
i wanted them to take the kyle
rittenhouse fundraiser down off of
gibson go they told me no
right um i didn't take that well so i've
been looking into these people ever
since there's a huge network behind this
crap there okay but basically what i
found was there's this russian thief
who is working with a bunch of
billionaires in silicon valley i think
he's laundering russian money okay
but that's a whole huge thing i actually
put up all that stuff
over on reddit
in uh r slash
sergey with a y
grisham g-r-i-s-h-i-n if you want to go
take a look at that later you can okay
but what how did how did what how did
you get because so so this data is
leaked out on the internet and you just
capture this data and then you've been
combing through it then is what you're
saying i got i got two copies of it
right right uh one copy was given to me
by an independent security researcher
and the other copy i obtained from
distributed denial of secrets which is a
website that gives
hacked data
to journalists and researchers
so they can legitimately you know it's
sometimes things get hacked and they
have
credit card information right right well
that's illegal for anyone to have
right right
uh
so you know someone like distributed
desiral secrets cleans all that credit
card info out and gives out the info to
investigative journalists
basically makes it legal to obtain right
right cleans it up a bit yeah yeah it
makes it so the feds don't come knocking
at your door right right right um we
don't want that we don't want that yeah
i want nothing to do with the feds man
anyway um so yeah i got two copies of
the data i i compared them
they matched so i'm like okay well this
must be
legitimate data uh at least for what was
leaked on the internet now
you know when we get into the slides
i'll tell you you know give send go has
not sent oh yes this was a legitimate
data breach
uh gibson go has also
as far as i can tell not notified their
donors that that they have they're legal
right yeah they're required to do that
by the law
however this is the funny part uh the
the cfo of the company a fellow named
jacob a wells you can find him on
twitter uh he's like the feds need to
investigate these damn hackers well
does that mean the hack is real right so
are you admitting to the fact that it is
right
like what
so that so the data not only not only
have you compared it to two sets but
also they're admitting that the data has
been leaked
i
they have not come out and said yeah we
had a data breach however
calling for the the
quote-unquote hackers yeah well
security research is is is the proper
term right security researchers
should be investigated
um it kind of feels like they're saying
it is you know you know yeah
right you wouldn't be you wouldn't give
any sort of attention to something that
was that was fraudulent you would only
do it for something that was legitimate
so
seems like
there's probably something of substance
there there's probably something of
substance um
however i will say you know there's a
couple things that are kind of funny one
like uh
every single news story i've seen about
this data leak uh they're they're
talking only about the people that were
included in the database right losing
their jobs
they don't talk about the data itself
which i think is [ __ ] so that that
brings up a good point because one story
i read um which kind of circulated
around pretty quickly was a guy named
benjamin pogue i think is how you say
his name p-o-g-u-e
he's from the dallas area um he and the
reason why it's so salacious is because
he owns a construction company or he is
the ceo of a construction company now
that his father started and his father
actually received a pardon for from
trump for tax fraud um which seems
significant that the guy whose family
got uh you know
pardons is giving money because it's not
only giving money to this particular
fund but they also paid for private jets
for the trump campaign i think it was
238 000 if i remember correctly uh the
number that was he it was it was ashley
pogue and
right husband and son
right exactly so nothing shady about
that right absolutely nothing nothing
nothing could be you know similar to
this thing and the trump card
right right totally separate i'm sure
because what you're going to tell us i i
have a feeling is that this data leak
has more to do with
just this one
i call it the ram ranchers convoy um
this one data at this one event this
data leak kind of has to do with maybe
many events that has happened
well so gives and go uh they did you
know they raised funds for written house
correct
um they raised funds for proud boys and
individuals to try to travel to dc for
january 6
and provide body armor
and provide you know hotel
was it was the was that was the words
was the words oath keeper in that uh in
that list as well or is it i did not
i i
i did not do that comparison however
this is what i will say the oath keepers
uh were also the subject of a data
breach their entire membership list was
leaked
i have not done a comparison between the
oath keepers data list and uh
this this freedom convoy data actually
actually what i'm working on now is i'm
trying to get as many of their
uh fundraiser data sets as i can
and do some analysis on those to see if
what i found in the freedom convoy data
matches the other data sets because
there's some
there's some not right stuff going on
yeah because
it seems like it's all it's it seems
like it's all related is what you're
saying not just not just money in but
possibly money out as well well i think
also what i read was um it was somebody
did do a maybe the intercept i think
might have done a comparison and i think
they found over 300 matches between the
oath keeper membership list and the
freedom convoy donors list that's well
so so my question would be uh so they
found the first name and last name
did they find the first name last name
in the same zip code and if they found
it first name last name in the same zip
code was it their credit card that they
used right is it their debit yeah that
that i don't know and because yeah you
got to see what i found right
okay so so you're saying you're saying
there's more to this than what we're
scratching the surface here yeah there's
more than just who donated uh right
there's some other stuff
that
does not make sense how i don't even
know how to say it it's it looks like
there are fake records so you're saying
you're saying the data looks like the
data's fraud or like it's like it's been
cooked those books have been cooked sort
of or
i think i think this is a highly
advanced
uh
money laundering operation i think there
are real records with real people
donating real money on real cards
right
and i also think that there
are fake
people
with donations through you know i i have
spent some time
online i wouldn't say like dark web but
i know a bunch of security researchers
they they congregate online in different
places and some of the chatter i've
heard is these look like compromise
credit card numbers that have been found
on
you know uh there are forums where you
can go and just buy lists of credit
cards yes right
um they're saying that yeah we've seen
these before so what you're so what
you're saying is this could possibly be
a ruse as to to try to make it seem
quote unquote legitimate so that way
money can siphon through um and and then
possib is there a possibility that these
other data sets from these other events
would show the same sort of um
that's what i want to look at that's
what i want to look at that's actually
that's one of the data comparisons i'm
doing right now i'm grabbing the data
sets and i'm pulling them down i mean
these are not you know
the data set from freedom convoy had 92
000 records right slightly over it's
like 92 844 or something like that but
yeah these are big huge comma separated
values
files
that i got to pull out dump into a
database write a bunch of queries pull
that out you know check the data right
so you'll probably have to clean up as
well before you can even any do sort of
any analysis
uh i'm actually not doing any cleanup on
the data uh because i want the data in
its raw format i want to massage the
data as little as possible so that when
i write the queries against the data i
get back exactly what gibson goes sees
so so so give it give us that in the
simplest terms possible because um
try to explain to the audience exactly
what you're saying are you saying you're
just trying to make sure the data is raw
as possible to see all the transactions
because it's actually are you looking at
the transactions the what would be the
money that is given from individual
whoever to the the trucker convoy as it
were right well i don't i don't want to
alter records because uh you know when i
present this to
big time reporters and i present this to
law enforcement i mean i've already i've
already presented it to the rcmp
um what is the rcmp that is the royal
canadian mounted police gotcha okay uh
and i've talked to a couple members of
the canadian parliament about it
um
it's it's actually funny
the american authorities are having a
problem because
the fbi says that because it's money
laundering it has to go to the secret
service right and the secret service
says because it deals with january 6 it
has to go to the fbi so they're trying
to fight
it
so they don't they don't know who's
holding the horse and or who's holding
the tail on who's [ __ ] the horse
but canada knows and they're like oh
yeah right yeah and canada's just like
give it here so that's so that's why
that's why you're talking to the mounted
police uh in canada is because they're
ready to
maybe make some action on this or at
least at least start to investigate
would be at least they're not playing
hot potato because that's what that
sounds like right yeah they're not
playing hot potato they're just like
yeah give me what you got right now
let's talk about it so got you got you
thumbs up to canada yeah well you know
uh punjabi what you're right
if we
we saw uh trudeau the other day um
in in uh in the uh the parliament in
public
and uh one of the most significant
moments when they're like he's like no
you
you're with nazis like you're with nazis
they have nazi flags and and uh you know
that was kind sort of his justification
for doing i i forget the exact name of
the order that he gave um
some kind of emergency order to say no
this is enough do you think some of do
you think some of what was leaked out of
this to show that some right it's not
just organic right that this is
coordinated right wing and it's not just
people in canada this is this is actors
from all around the world do you think
that's what led him to say okay enough's
enough we got enough evidence we're not
going to continue this garbage anymore
well it's foreign funding of
basically domestic terror i mean
me and gabe have been talking about this
last week about this because we think
the ram ranch thing is the funniest part
of it but in all
seriousness but because that's the
actual protest right but but to to to
put all seriousness to it
is that it really does seem like they're
using this anti-vaxx anti-mask anti-you
know what whatever it is like the
anti-covid thing they're using that to
really try to propagate their their
anti-democracy message and really sow
doubt into not just not just the people
in the right-wing movement but to leak
this this doubt into democracy outside
of this movement so people like well
maybe democracy isn't all that great
right like like to try to perpetuate
this and it's and it and i it seems like
they're trying to
you know kind of do a um a pre you know
like a test run right test run for what
this is okay so historically
uh mussolini you know before world war
ii when mussolini came to power
mussolini actually paid a bunch of
truckers to run around blockade [ __ ]
beat people up
cause havoc
this is the exact same playbook right
exact and here's the thing it's not just
canada right they were having this in
france right they're supposed to be
having one here in the united states
yeah good luck they're having one in
germany they're having one in spain uh
they've got crap going on in portugal
right
this is not organic this is a
coordinated guys coordinated effort yeah
yeah and and here's you know you got to
pay for soldiers right
how are they paying for soldiers well
they're doing this gibson go is what
you're thinking
i'm thinking that yeah right yeah i
really am so so let's get into
why that is significant if they're using
this gibson goes so
explain how because
gofundme shut them down right and do you
think that gofundme shut them down
because they were like they've seen this
like they've seen this in their day
they're like whoa there's something kind
of fishy here you think that's why they
shut them down are there other reasons
like they said publicly well i i would i
would say this uh if you remember during
the kyle rittenhouse fundraiser on
gibson go discover cut it off right just
immediately cut it off never said why
right
right
then gofundme is like yeah no not
happening right right
um
and and gibson go was like just come
over to us give us all your money here's
another weird thing i found out when i
was looking through this data set
go fund me cut off
the freedom convoy
on the fourth of february right
the first donations to this gibson go
trucker convoy
uh thing were received on february 1st
three days before gofundme cut them off
so you did did that you are you thinking
that they did this in preparation that
gofundme shut them down or that they
knew they would i mean are that they
just one it just shows some sort of
pre-planning
i don't know what but there's right
there was there was uh what do they call
that malice a forethought i guess
right they're they're they're
they were they saw something in what was
going to happen with the marketability
of this
of this campaign so they were trying to
hedge their bet but there was something
i was interested in looking into to see
through the wayback machine to see
exactly what was going on and on the
fifth there was a
some big changes that are happening to
the website in terms of like uh traffic
that's coming in so explain to the
audience where the wayback machine is to
you gabe so the wayback machine allows
you to go back it's an internet archive
and so you can look up websites you know
uh past accounts if you want to look up
like donald trump's past tweets if you
want or anything like that it takes a
snapshot in in a moment like a moment in
time of a website on the internet so
it's like a screen it's like a screen
yeah you can still interact with it too
like you can go around and navigate from
that moment that it was taking a
snapshot of so that's what i was i was
taking a look at the website and i was
noticing that on the fifth so assuming
that all this traffic came in on the
after the fourth his first donation
brought the site down
which also comes in a question of some
of the stuff that you'll probably talk
about well
so it's it's even more than that uh
as as soon as gibson go
flipped on the trucker convoy
uh
donation they
they started getting what's called ddos
and that's just basically when you throw
a bunch of packets from your computer
you know tens of thousands of computers
across the internet
trying to overload the computer that
runs the website right and that's that's
called a distributed denial of service
or an exhaust and for anyone listening
that's also what has happened to ukraine
which we've now obviously would you know
it didn't take a genius to figure out
was probably russia that was doing it
but yeah they're the ones that were
behind the ddos attack toward ukraine so
yeah well also uh you know on on the
radicalized truce survives podcast a
couple episodes ago we interviewed the
former president of estonia uh tomas
ilves
and he said that yeah the exact same
thing happened
uh when russia was going to try to do
some some violence against their country
is before that happened
all their banks got ddosed a bunch of
government websites went down russians
russia did so this is it's like an
internet weapon that both sides have
like the good guy you know i mean
russia right because civilization
very much depends on the internet now
right and so like if you bring that down
you're bringing down a lot of dominoes
in the way which is communication
banking i mean basically civilization
for that society is brought down to its
knees
so so forgive me here it seems like so
far and it seems like maybe this is
going to be a theme it seems like
everything right-wing and anti-democracy
in this world all roads all those roads
lead back to one spot and that spot
seems to be putin
um am i am i am i wrong by thinking that
everything we said so far it seems to be
that way i think putin i think putin has
his tentacles through a bunch of rich
people all across the globe
you mean possibly like real estate you
know fake real estate oh we know about
fake real estate the thing most people
don't know about is they don't know
about the fact that there's a guy named
yuri milner m-i-l-n-e-r and he gave
millions of dollars to twitter millions
of dollars to facebook
jared kushner got like i think half a
million dollars who's jared kushner that
name sounds familiar jared kushner uh
he's this he's this tall pasty looking
[ __ ] he's like a life-sized
porcelain doll yeah
you should hear him speak he doesn't
easy no thank you right
he doesn't speak often but you know yeah
i have i have nothing uh that man has
nothing of interest that i want to hear
ever but seriously this this seems to be
a very common theme with this with this
um
how how basically the how to guide
of
uh how to question democracy right
because it seems like the goal of
any of this even even right now
where we have this weird situation where
the republican party the gqp in this
country
is cheering on putin
instead of
instead of being on the side of american
and allied soldiers and their safety
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
they want to bring biden into it like
just take the president of the united
states out of the picture for this for
just one [ __ ] second just one
second the commander-in-chief's
job is to keep as many american soldiers
as safely as possible as he can so you
take the the commander-in-chief
president biden who is now the president
obviously we know but just take him out
of the picture literally they are siding
with putin instead of american soldiers
safety it really is [ __ ] i mean
you've got franklin graham over here
that's saying pray for
me
okay so that's when you bring that up
religion religion is one of the things
that ties russia and the far right now
the russian orthodox church is like very
gung-ho about the jesus stuff right well
so are people like franklin graham and
the evangelicals but the funny thing is
even underneath that
there is some crazy cult [ __ ] going on i
don't know did you ever see uh you know
mike flynn
in an evangelical church we landed on
our podcast when he
because jim put that video together your
other co-host put that video together
and draw the comparison online and then
heidi came on and we played it and we
got her reaction um so
i i i believe there is a lot of um
insidious things happening and it all
all these roads you know everyone wants
to say you know trump's behind all this
i don't think he's smart enough um but i
don't know but lieutenant at best right
he's right he's not smart enough to be a
general in this right well we actually
talked to speaking of oath keepers and
who's taking orders from hugh we talked
to uh dakota adams who is the estranged
son of uh stewart rhodes the i like that
kid he's cool he is he's [ __ ] super
smart he's smart he's super smart so uh
and he knows and he knows the ins and
outs of oat keepers in the militia and
more more than anything he knows the ins
and outs of the map of stuart rhodes
mind and how that [ __ ] chaos works
but he was saying he was telling us the
other day in an interview um we we was
talking to him about the hearing of the
detention hearing that they were having
for uh stuart rhodes and which they
ultimately
the judge remained the pre-child
attention but we asked him about the
orders who was giving orders for the qrf
and he was saying well stewart was in
charge of that order but it in the
signal chat from that day it seems as if
that the qrf team was saying who cares
if you get the orders or not what's make
something up basically right so so
stuart was getting orders from somebody
so somebody was getting orders from
someone else like like everyone thinks
oh well this is just one one
spot in this in this timeline no this is
a coordinated effort there was a
conspiracy and when the isolated events
these are all tied together right and i
just had this feeling that this this ram
ranch trucker convoy [ __ ] up in ottawa
that i believe
i believe
that this is all a coordinated effort
in the continuation of the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup as i call it from january
6. like this is their attempt they're
continuing this cheeto dust kangaroo
coup on our government because i believe
that putin believes if he can take down
american democracy then he will be safe
um and and he can be the tyrant that he
really wants to be well it's not just
the united states right
uh but that's a lot of people do you
think that's the don't you think that's
the crown jewel here in democracy oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah well the reason the
reason putin wants america right is
because we got all the [ __ ] guns
right nobody has a military like we do
right and if if trump was president
and he's like yeah putin's my boy i'm
going to back him up suddenly putin's
got all our [ __ ] guns too he can do
whatever he wants to germany france
england whatever nato you but also it's
quite it's quite the mantle mantelpiece
to be like the u.s i got the [ __ ] us
everyone else can go [ __ ] themselves and
this is the real prize and if he has us
like you said it just it just
it would be a domino effect to be like
we got the us no one else stands a
chance and that's kind of that's kind of
why i like watching joe biden treat
putin like a little [ __ ] you know i
mean you know you know true truly truly
titans like every every little moo chess
move that putin tries to make here
biden's like yeah we know what the [ __ ]
you're doing like it's not [ __ ]
rocket science we can see you we know
what the hell is going on you know and
he's not taking any [ __ ] he's not you
know so i i you know whether he plays it
out correctly or not you know time only
tell in history will give us a good
image of how joe biden handled this
whole thing
but so far
it seems to be successful in the in the
act of we're not just going to let putin
run rush shot over the entire world and
run rush out over the truth more than
anything because i think that's
ultimately what putin's trying to do is
is trying to sell this [ __ ] stupid
lie that somehow he has to be justified
and and biden
putin is mentally ill
i mean just period end of story uh he is
he is greedy as [ __ ]
um
i i don't know if you know i i've talked
to some some historians and some
professors and people who've like made
it their life's work to study putin
putin erased like the first like five to
ten years of his life like it's gone
there is no documentation
uh
the stories that have come out of russia
is that
his his mother didn't want him his
mother gave him away to a man who may or
may not have abused him physically and
sexually as a child
uh and obviously if that happens to you
that's gonna [ __ ] up your world view
it's really hard you know if you're not
getting therapy and dealing with that
um and and putin just turned into kind
of a wicked greedy
dominating bastard um
you know look at his palace he's
building i mean he was in the kgb look
what he did the kgb he he came out of
saint petersburg right saint petersburg
huge
huge uh russian mafia town so he had
dealings with the russian mafia he has
turned the russian mafia into the
government of russia i i don't think
he's a legitimate governor in any way
shape or form i think
not at all he's a mentally ill thug you
know you know the thing i i like best
about this whole putin thing and then
we'll get to the the data here because
one more thing because i i think putin
is a little [ __ ] that's why he he runs
around with this [ __ ] shirt off and
[ __ ] you know this modern horse back
going nipples gotta
breathe right it's this whole [ __ ]
alpha cuck thing as we say here you know
on our show the alpha cup thing this
these these [ __ ] guys these [ __ ]
guys who think they're alphas and they
have to like the alpha doesn't have to
show they're an alba like they don't
have to do that type of [ __ ] the alpha
just is that's how it works and and i
think it's funny to watch the guy who
thinks he's so [ __ ] tough have you
ever seen him like try to meet someone
for the first time with this coronavirus
like he's standing like 30 feet [ __ ]
away from him he's oh he's scared no one
[ __ ] he's terror he is completely
[ __ ] terrified of coronavirus he is
[ __ ] afraid and it is well i'm sure
mortality is that is the only thing he
really fears because if he's dead then
he can't rule right he can't have power
right right which which oddly enough is
also peter thiel's big [ __ ] oh yeah
right yeah immortal too yeah exactly
what is this phrase he's trying to
expand human life or there's some phrase
of like nah that [ __ ] just wants
to live forever and run everything yeah
[ __ ] that guy right [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy
well what's funny about that guy so he
had this he had this uh parabiosis
company uh i forget the name of it it's
like ambrosia or something right the big
idea about that company was they were
gonna take the blood
from young people and put it in old
people and take the blood from old
people and put in young people where he
got that idea
is from a russian
philosopher jesus christ called fyodorov
and there's this whole russian school of
thought called cosmism right
c-o-s-m-i-s-m and that's it it sounds
completely real and not made i mean
that's that's [ __ ] crazy right oh
[ __ ] i mean
right yeah but that's also the uh that's
also the joke of having a blood boy
where i don't know if you guys
they made fun of it they made fun of it
in silicon valley uh the tv show but
there's this thing about how especially
because i i use well i still work in
tech but i used to uh live in in the
in nsf
and that was always something that we
talked about is like the rich you know
continue to be rich but the rich want to
live longer and so the rich always have
this like blood boy essentially which is
like the youthful person
in shape is able to donate the blood to
make the other person it's like their
mobile fountain of youth essentially is
what the idea is so it's based in truth
right well it's not based on truth right
right it's based on this russian crazy
[ __ ]
they make fun of it so people don't take
it seriously
but some of them actually believe this
[ __ ] it sounds like like kind of
like queuing on [ __ ] right like like oh
yeah
you know this thing
well i mean you look at the cult [ __ ]
with mike flynn and like he believes
this [ __ ] right well mike flynn
go go down a little further down the
rungs there and go to mike lindell that
[ __ ] crackhead
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] gay
so the thing about people
people can be manipulated right right
and
if people have a drug problem they're
even easier to manipulate right
especially if they got a [ __ ] ton of
money right
yeah i think i think i know where you're
going with this
you know another question i have about
the the pillow company is you know it
came i i remember it coming around
whatever it was 2008 2009 whenever um
they did a lot of their sales online
right and and once we look through this
gibson go data i want to ask
you what i'm saying yeah yeah
i don't know
right maybe maybe just all these things
might have like a spider web like a very
seditious spider whip yeah i mean i
would i also wouldn't be surprised if uh
if someone were to investigate and do
some digging that you find out that a
lot of people like dinesh d'souza and
also mike lindell use these
opportunities to give away things and
they're they're they also work as each
other's referral system i don't know if
you've ever noticed that they're always
promoting one thing and you get the
other free okay okay okay i got to say
wait a second i got i got to say
something real good because the funniest
thing i've [ __ ] seen online with mike
lindell and hawking that [ __ ] is rudy
giuliani trying to sell his slippers he
has this guy
oh my god dude on his youtube channel
see that's how he says schlipper's
that's a guy who you know is broke as
[ __ ]
and they're speaking of using speaking
of using people there you go like
they're they're all it's just one big
[ __ ] circle jerk um and and i it's it
would not be surprising
um high five would not be surprising if
you're right that the circle jerk even
in the data you can see the [ __ ]
circle jerk right out right up there for
everyone to see well i mean one of the
things that peter thiel is really
[ __ ] good at is
it's it's called the network effect okay
he hooks people up
he's got this guy doing this thing this
guy doing this thing this guy doing this
thing so what the first guy does
actually benefits the third guy but he
has to run through the second guy to get
to the third guy right like if you look
at a map of peter thiel's connections in
silicon valley that dude is everywhere
right he i used
[Music]
earlier on when he had the founders fund
i don't even know if that's still in
existence or if he's like congresswoman
is still around i believe so tell us
about t peter jill a little bit more
like his background like what other
things if you started doing a little
googling would you say hey that i know
that thing like that that that specific
event and that piece of news i would
know about that what what other news
would we know peter deal from well he's
backing jd vance in my home state of
ohio and jamie vance's
right i mean jd vance's whole book was
oh look how awful life was so i'm gonna
run away right what kind of book is that
whatever jd vance far right q anon maga
bs
uh he's also promoting another one i
think it's liz cheney's challenger out
in arizona a guy goes on there and like
man handles a rifle like he's some
[ __ ] hunter or want to be soldier
like
don't they all dude
peter thiel brought down gawker because
gawker outed him as being gay
now when you say brought down gawker you
mean through the hulk hogan
uh yeah yeah well he funded hulk hogan's
lawsuit right
against gawker right
because he wanted to destroy like he
played the long game on that that's what
makes him so scary he's [ __ ] smart
right like this is not a stupid person
right he's a billionaire
but peter thiel is
i like to say that peter thiel is a
threat to democracy and a threat to
humanity and he has to be stopped
right well peter peter thiel gave an uh
a speech at the cato institute where he
he said
i do not believe democracy and freedom
are compatible anymore
he said [ __ ] [ __ ] does that mean
that means i want to get rid of [ __ ]
democracy so i can be free to do
whatever the [ __ ] i want right that's
right i can i can own it all yeah and i
think that's what he's trying to do uh
one of the you know one other thing
that's huge about peter thiel is
uh 2016
he was at the rnc here in in cleveland
um
a guy named joel zamel who is an israeli
[Music]
cyber securities unit 8200
he was running surveillance on the
republicans he peter thiel joel zamel uh
jack posobiac mike cernovich mike flynn
they all got together and made this
thing called maga3x uh with milo uh
it sounds like a really shitty protein
bar by the way
yes
like maga3x it sounds like something
that garbage that you would wouldn't
want to [ __ ] eat but you know well
what what happened was the rnc ate it
and it is brainwashed them all and
turned them into what they are today
right right
a vast majority of republicans are
compromised if they're not compromised
they're just on board because they're
mind [ __ ]
um
yeah
it's god damn dude just thinking about
all this [ __ ] man sorry
um
but yeah bag of three x was kind of the
start of q anon right and there were
troll groups that broke out and
pushed
uh
they pushed the messaging
the real scary part is and i can't prove
this but i think
between palantir
uh
if you've ever seen the movie people you
may know by charles creel uh and cat
gallon um
they were collecting data on people with
vulnerabilities people with
emotional problems financial problems
relationship problems grief problems
they were catching these people at their
most vulnerable they were collecting
data on them and they were sucking them
into the church right which i don't have
a problem with church sometimes church
is good for people sometimes they need
it but
it makes it very easy to radicalize
people and turn them into a cult right
and i think i think that's you know i
mean if you look at keyword on that's
what it is it's a cult if you look at
the rnc that's what it is now it's a
cult right
so do you believe that that possibly the
data that we're going to look at here in
a minute do you believe that some of
this has to do with maybe some of that
cult like stuff like the q and on cult
and
i think they well let's go through the
data and i'll show you something that
pops up
i don't think it pops up organically i
think it was put there
we'll talk about it so let's talk gibson
go and you know what does this data show
us
and this is uh the fundraising data from
the freedom convoy now disclaimer right
uh it's hack data
i did a comparison between the two data
sets from ddos right and an independent
researcher they matched
i'm guessing it's legitimate
if it isn't legitimate
ignore this this this is not real if it
is legitimate
there needs to be authorities looking at
this hard and not just not just the
canadian mounted police but also
american authorities possible other
authorities in other countries it seems
like um well definitely canada
definitely america i don't know you know
i don't know what kind of fundraising
they were doing in germany or spain or
france um
i do know
i do know that uh the yellow vests
protests in france
i don't think those were organic in any
way shape or form right and there's part
of the reason for that is because their
website
uh
was run by a guy from denver
mm-hmm
like he had the the registration for
their website
yeah
so real real technology companies right
right technology is working
it seems real french you know when some
dude from denver's got the website you
know i'm just saying well i mean you
look at uh wikileaks you know wikileaks
was used against hillary clinton right
and podesta and the emails
the
registrar the people who
[Music]
make that site available on the internet
is a german company run by a german
billionaire named dahmer ruth
but the actual company that hosts the
wikileaks stuff is psi dash usa which is
out of michigan seems fishy i don't know
just a little
all right so
um yeah technologies and networks man
they're building networks across the
globe as far as i can tell
uh all right so you know first thing is
gibson go says oh yeah we don't take any
money i mean it's right there on their
website it says zero right
uh except when i went through the data
yeah what do you what do you mean by you
mean give singo doesn't take any of the
money that's transferred back and forth
is that what you're saying they're not
supposed to
they say they take zero percent of any
fundraiser okay okay i'm just i just
want to clarify for for where we're at
now it does say you know third-party
processing fees and 30 cents but you got
to opt in right
uh you can also tip them i know there's
that
oh this this is just the equation saying
like we take nothing processing takes
2.9 total is 2.9 plus 30. okay well and
so here here's what's interesting is
they used to have three
uh payment processors they used to have
paypal
which was started by peter thiel and
elon musk right okay they used to have
uh we pay which was jpmorgan chase
paypal and jp morgan chase both cut off
gibson go they said we're not we're not
doing stuff for them anymore
that leaves them with only their third
payment processor which is a company out
of ireland called stripe
right
except
if you look at stripe
stripe was founded and funded by peter
thiel
elon musk
and a company named sequoia capital so
you control the money you know
well if you control the money that's
right um all right so what i found going
through the data there's this column
called two gsg amounts that that to me
says two gives and go right
they made over a half a million dollars
hmm just so
so zero percent of our 100 percent of
zero apparently equals a half a million
bucks yeah yeah i'm no mathematician but
that doesn't add up right
i mean i'm just saying 100 of zero does
seem to add up to about a half million
bucks
yeah yeah and that's the actual number
right down there at the bottom that's
that's uh five seven two seven four
seven nine four yeah that's so almost
six hundred thousand really if you're oh
yeah coming up if you're rounding up
it's almost six hundred thousand dollars
yeah is is a hundred percent of zero
right exactly exactly
yeah um oh okay so then you know i just
a rough look at the data
uh here's all the the ones on the right
are all the high number donations right
and these should have something called a
fin send report which is their the
financial authority that's supposed to
track money laundering in america in
canada because what you're saying is
because what you're saying is like it's
like when when um this is when you go to
the bank and you may write a check for
like 10 or 15 000
and the bank has to tell the federal
government hey
by the way they wrote this check here's
the transaction and then you know they
just it's just like recorded it's not
like someone investigates it or anything
like that it's just recorded on a log
basically but that's why yeah they gotta
file that sars report that's like a
suspicious activity report right that's
why when you see people like you know i
think it's been discussed in movies and
tv shows but when you have someone who's
like all right listen i need this many
people to go to these different banks
and take out this much money under 10k
random amounts so that it doesn't raise
any red flags so it just looks like
normal as opposed to going over that
amount or doing exactly the same amount
and raising a red flag in this all of a
sudden and getting sent to fincen you
know what's funny about this you know
what's funny about this in politics
when they were debating on the house
floor the the coveted relief bill the
republicans are really [ __ ] pissed
off we're really [ __ ] hell bent on
making sure that that ten thousand
dollar amount didn't uh equal to about
three i wonder i wonder if they felt
like they would be under attack if that
amount was changed from ten thousand
three maybe it make difficult to uh you
know move money i'm just saying to move
money around you know they've set it up
now where if you're doing money through
paypal or any online anything and you're
doing a business and you've got over 600
bucks now you got to report over 600
bucks right exactly right and there's a
reason for that
well and that's and that's what got
republicans so bent out of shape um is
because you know you had to you had to
report which it's it's kind of goes back
to a certain person's tax returns or
financial records if the financial
records would prove that you're not
doing anything wrong why wouldn't you
want them why would you try to be
stopped them from being disclosed as
opposed to disclosing tony
it's too complicated right i got
something to say to rich people all
right same [ __ ] you've been saying to us
for years if you've got nothing to worry
about you've got nothing to hide right
you know exactly why you're still being
out of shape right why are you still
lying
don't worry about it why are you so
worried about your zero percent your
hundred percent of your zero equaling
six hundred thousand dollars why are you
so worried about this uh two things i do
want to point out on this slide though
uh you see those two sideways right
arrows and they got that that a u circle
thing
in computer programming you know when
you're translating what's called a
character set like there aren't just
letters or numbers or like
or ascii these are different character
sets and sometimes when you translate
character sets
things get messed up so if you look at
this quote those are supposed to be
quotation marks
and i look through the rest of the data
there are quotation marks in the rest of
the data that au thing
that's a translation error
and my question is
was it their website
that mistranslated that and dumped it
into their database or was somebody
dumping data into their database outside
of their website
and that caused the errors okay so so
explain that in a little more simple
terms because i am confused so let's
let's let's say let's say this
information that you're looking at
you're saying it comes from maybe
outside maybe inside but but explain why
that is significant i'm going to use
some visual aids here here's a visual
aid right
this is my website this is my front end
okay
behind that website i have this database
over here here's my database and you can
see it's filling up with data right
right
here's the thing
if this is all messed up
if if they're not coming through the
website
right is it possible
that they've got another way
to put data into this database
that is not this right so in other words
in other words is there data coming in
through a back door where
gibson go gives and go seems to be the
front door that all the data like when
you would donate to this to this thing
rather you donate five dollars or five
thousand dollars right you assume
everything's coming through the front
door but what you're saying is is
there's a possibility that donations are
coming through a back door right
yeah right because if you were to like
so this right here this is a quote this
is what i'm assuming is somebody can
send a message right in support of the
freedom convoy so the assumption here is
that if i'm going to type in an open
text field area i would put you know
shift quote and then my message and
shift quote you know and it would assume
that it would be able to interpret that
actual
uh symbol right however and then what
what hi-fi is bringing out here is that
it was
was not interpreted the way that it
should have been
but a different way and so that's where
that question comes that that is a
translation but here's the thing that's
there's not just one or two there's
literally thousands
this is just one example
this is just one example okay i just
wanted to point this out just out of
curiosity did you run any sort of
analysis to look at uh if there were
like
copy pasta kind of uh
these quotes were there more of the same
quotes happen like identical questions i
haven't i haven't run any uh unique
values on the comments yet but yeah that
is something i do have in my dude i've
got like a list of like 100 100
different things i need to do this data
that's one of them right i wouldn't i
mean i wouldn't be surprised if you're
going to end up seeing like this is the
exact same quote in the exact same
format
sent from either the same
person or why would people but why why
would why would someone okay because i
want to break this down simple terms why
would someone when they go donate five
bucks right why would they put a
specific specific like to the character
of what they're typing in why would they
write a specific thing in the comment
section other than like thanks for
letting me donate to the
the truckers right why is that so
significant why is it so important to
know and why what does it do if they
were to type in something very specific
in that field where you would normally
write
i love the truckers or or make america
great again even though it's canada
whatever you whatever you would type in
that field well if i am right in my
assessment what we are looking at is a
combination of real life stuff
and fake stuff right right
real life stuff has the appear you know
it's people typing actual comments in
there
like i was like i was saying i love the
truckers whatever it would be whatever
it would be but to make the fake stuff
look like the real stuff right
you want to have them as close as
possible right
right so
let's put a bunch of fake comments in
there that looks like they could be real
people comments
right right so this may be where the
ruse comes in that we were talking about
earlier where
it's possible that
there are real donations but there are
donations that are sidious and there's
there's a
more of a goal about those donations and
that money pumping through this fund
than just giving to the truckers the
other the other thing that i you know
that i'm kind of thinking of right now
is
to your question tony about like why
would somebody do this instead of just
say i love the truckers right well right
if someone you know like hifi were to go
to the data obviously this is a red flag
but if you saw a bunch of comments that
said i love the truckers or i stand with
the truckers that were all verbatim you
might come into question and say like
well this is odd however the appearance
of a quote
of someone else
if somebody were to copy the quote from
online and put it in here as a comment
you would say well that's not uncommon
because that person copied and pasted it
in
but if they had the same comment that
was like from a person that said i stand
with the truckers or i love the truckers
or whatever and you were to see that in
a high frequency of times
that out of the gate might cause a red
flag but here as a quote you'd be like
oh well they're just quoting some so
it's just that's why it looks the same
what is interesting is i found at least
a
about
uh probably about 15 to 20 records where
they started a quote like thomas payne
said
but then there's nothing after it yeah
well he did say you know he did say
nothing at one point potentially
whatever script was running that
some character cut off the message yeah
very possible so you're saying so you're
saying even that this is all automated
like this is it's possible it is
possible that a lot of this is automated
okay um okay so the next question is
this donation right here should this
donation have a fence and report this
donation is two five thousand dollars
right which together equals ten thousand
dollars
made one minute apart
if you look at that donation date right
one minute apart now first off how the
[ __ ] did you enter all your information
twice in a minute that's impressive as
[ __ ] right especially if you're making a
five thousand dollar you know a five
thousand dollar drop yeah well how do
you write all yeah write your name write
your email address write your credit
card number write your cs or you know
your csv code
and then send and then do it again
it whatever
uh it just it seems like it should have
a fincen report yeah right so that's
this that was just obvious stuff that
was just like high level just like kind
of combing through it real fast right
mm-hmm
um
then it gets really [ __ ] weird
like really weird
okay so the first thing when i get data
you know i said i matched these two data
sets to make sure my data was valid
right
but there's more than just matching data
sets to make sure it's valid you
actually have to go and look at the data
itself
washington post went and they said oh
look at all these zip codes obviously
this is valid data and they map to this
so this this map that you have here is
not your map this is washington no no
this is you can just see bottom right
washington post they just took it they
just accepted it it looks like right
don't you just say oh yeah it's
legitimate data right totally it totally
looks like an 18 d or verizon wireless
map absolutely it must be legitimate
must be legitimate
um
so
i went and i looked at different things
i didn't just look at zip codes i looked
at email address to zip code first name
last name to email address
email address to credit card type
this is what i found man over 2 000
email addresses appear twice what the
[ __ ]
204 appear three times
46
and you can see the numbers right right
right there is one email address that
appears 16 [ __ ] times now wait a wait
a second that seems that seems totally
fine now wait a second now wait no
because because if i wanted to if i
wanted to donate 16 times i might use my
email address the same email address
each time and that is absolutely fair
and i understand that and that is
organic right i did look through some of
the duplicates and i found there were
some people like i was able to identify
people and i'll show you that later on
there were organic multiple donations
right
right but what makes these different
well let me show you
so i did what's called a sniff test
right and i went and i looked at some of
these duplicates oh i do a sniff test it
just not has to do with data
i'm just saying what i'm just saying
when you pick the t-shirt off the floor
yeah yeah
yeah
so what i found here here was the first
one i looked at right and this was four
records so i have four donations i have
four different names
as you can see right there donation
first donation you're saying the first
and last name are completely different
on each one of these is where you are on
each one we have alyssa jordan
richard and jerry
right okay it sounds like all of them
sounds like a whole family of them yeah
yeah except all of them have the same
email address
with four different zip codes what the
[ __ ] this is this isn't like a house you
guys can't just share emails what the
[ __ ] going on right what the [ __ ] well
so here's my thought right
maybe these emails are emails that have
somebody that will answer any questions
to that email but they're using that to
launder the donations to that email does
that make sense like hey i've got this
one
email the email is the contact point in
other words yeah yeah we don't have
phone numbers right it's like if
anything goes awry and they need to
respond
there's a person that might have the
email but there might be these tentacles
of donations that are tied back to that
and they're trying to maybe they're
trying to hide by different zip codes
and different names of who actually has
that email right maybe that's the thing
you look at this one there's three from
the united states there's one from
canada right
i actually went out and found the email
address and i did find the email address
it's in japan
so what are you saying so
three people from the us and one person
from canada are using an email address
from
japan yeah and it's and i found the
guy's youtube channel totally this
totally seems not suspicious at all not
just well
i'm i'm kind of wondering is he just
giving the okay sign up there in his
header
so wait a second who is this is this guy
is this guy in the youtuber is he is he
broadcasting from japan or is he where
is he broadcasting from well it says his
location is japan i didn't really go
into his videos uh okay but i i flipped
through and yeah he's he's a diver
he's
there were some videos that are in japan
like the the scenery behind him is
japanese i have japanese families so
right right it's not just some dude
behind or in front of a green screen no
dave knows actually gabe knows nothing
about dudes in front of green screens at
all
by by the way by the way just just to be
in full disclosure
green screens
right uh yeah so they're using this
email from this person supposedly in
japan but they're saying oh no we're
three americans and a canadian is any of
the names is any of the names that
appear on this list the name of the are
appear to be the name of the guy that
has a youtube channel no yeah
there's also a comment over here that
says the reason the american eagle oh
that that makes sense i mean perfect i
wonder like is that part of a fuller
like a more full quote yes
i kind of i kind of smashed the data up
so i could fit it all on one screen
but uh you know if you want to look at
the data sometime i'll i'll gladly walk
through it with you there's all sorts of
crazy but here's here here's the really
important part right so 205 dollars in
donations
four zip codes four names
email address in japan and every single
donation is on a different type of
credit card one is a visa debit one is a
mastercard credit card one is a visa
credit card and one is a mastercard
debit card what the [ __ ] so not so no so
not only is it different people who have
apparently no ties to this email address
but also each one of those transactions
is on a completely different card
yeah and you would think if it was like
one person pretending to be four people
they'd use the same card at least twice
maybe right like i've got a credit card
and i've got a bank card i could i could
you know yeah switch is this the whole
is this the whole uh
kevin hart thing i got a savings account
i got a checking account i got a
transfer money from the checkings to the
savings it's a long thing
what the [ __ ]
right right i i mean it it really
because i mean if you think about it
like the only thing that really is
really suspicious
about this thing is that all four of
these are under one email right like
because you could see how four different
transactions would have four different
zip codes would have four different
cards right but the thing that is tying
them all to this one thing is that one
email address or am i wrong it's all
it's all that one email address and it's
almost like four different people didn't
just know
to use
you know randomly pick this email
address out of their ass pluck it out of
their ass and put it in because you know
obviously they would pick this person's
email address to put on there because
what's interesting here is uh like
clearly you know whether these are
legitimate credit cards or you have an
array of stolen credit cards and you're
running through a script that's just
using the same login info and then
saying great pull this card pull that
card pull this card
so so do we know that's what it seems
like potentially yeah do we know if the
names in the zip codes because they i
and maybe i'm wrong that i don't know
because that you'd have to have the
credit card information you'd have to
have this
well because most of the time when you
do it when you do it it just the number
on the card has to match the zip code
that's all right exactly it doesn't have
anything to do with the name a lot of
times you have it has to match the card
of course everyone knows this if you
type at something and wrong when you're
trying to buy something on the internet
right the card the expiration date and
possibly the zip code and then the the
the cb uh with the cbc code or whatever
it is the three digit code on the back
right so all those things that's what
they're matching they don't care about
the the ad the email address or the name
on the card or the or the address
specifically sometimes just the zip code
but if you look at all the articles that
have been written about hey we contacted
so and so whose name appears in the data
they're not calling these people
they're
emailing them
right
so
how do you know the person answering
your email is that person right exactly
yeah
i don't know well i mean i mean you can
only go by the the information but we do
know that
some of the donors that
information has been leaked
have confirmed that they were
actual
donors yes
which make the data set seem pretty
legitimate if it's full of this stuff
like i said man i think i think we got a
mixture of real and fake right i think
that's what makes it so hard to spot
that's where the ruse is here because
yeah because a lot of journalists picked
out some of these big donors and you
know
put them on blast but maybe you're on to
something that it's more it's not this
isn't about the big donors this isn't
about the 20 000 this isn't about the 70
000 donations i mean maybe that has a
story behind it but what you're saying
is is that that's the distraction right
right exactly right that's what i you
know that but also there's the if you
get the small donations right there's a
different story that you can tell
right it's the average person makes
small contributions like any grassroots
effort right you've got small donations
that come in and accumulate
but the frequency and the amount that
are made between these donors make it
seem like a lot of people
legitimately are backing this movement
when in reality the appearance of yes
that's right and that's where the ruse
is so is there any other information
that you have that shows
that uh that more backs is up i knew you
would
oh dude i got so much
and i actually kept this short
right yeah sure all right so here here
we have george right
and george was nice enough to leave the
q anon slogan save our children of
course his donation name of course
uh why not george why not yeah yeah
george george made five donations 20 20
bucks a pop
uh all we have oh and he has uh two zip
codes one in arizona one in california
okay fine yeah yeah one email address
one email address that makes sense that
makes sense
except when you look into his email
address
george no longer owns his domain and his
email server his dns and his domain are
all hosted in uh norway
[Laughter]
so what what is it is there because you
know i uh there's certain companies out
there like godaddy and a few others that
you know they they host these things is
there a specific like a really big
well-known
company that possibly could be hosting
this or is this just like this is this
this is through a company called
the menace shop
oh i've never heard i i never heard of
them until i looked up this domain right
right it just seems a little weird that
a guy who possibly could have two homes
one in arizona one in california this is
giving me the same vibes as the
anti-abortion website in texas where
they tracked it back and it ended up not
being located in the u.s and then there
was a whole epic connection and
well we could talk about the epic hack
sometime too
oh [ __ ] these [ __ ] these right-wing
[ __ ] i just have to say that
i just have to say because this this is
you know this this you're calling it a
sniff test this isn't a [ __ ] this isn't
a [ __ ] sniff this i fight this is
obvious this is [ __ ] obvious what is
going on they they they obviously they
obviously have been doing this um
and peter t or whoever um
creating this ruse to to raise money and
not only raise money but to possibly
launder money and and more than anything
make these things look [ __ ]
legitimate to where they do undermine
democracy it is all a [ __ ] house of
cards i've said this for a long time and
i've said it privately and publicly i
believe that donald trump doesn't have
near as much support as this country
believes and i don't just mean [ __ ]
right wingers i mean that's on the left
think y'all he's got all these rallies
and the support and look at the [ __ ]
polls and all
i think it's all [ __ ] i think the
biggest [ __ ] ruse in the biggest
house of cards is that these that that
somehow people actually [ __ ] support
outright support right-wing causes and
right-wingness and right-wing net they
like neo-nazis and they want to support
the [ __ ] i think it's all [ __ ]
ruse and they've been running this [ __ ]
and making this you know psyop or
whatever you want to call it to convince
us all that this is some big [ __ ]
thing that's going to take over the
world you know i i will say this they
are a minority right
but do not underestimate these
[ __ ] well that will take over
if they can because i think i think
you're you're on to something there and
the reason why i think you're
understanding because i think it's a
smaller percentage than what we'd like
to admit but even that small percentage
here and around the world that's a lot
of [ __ ] people that's a lot of
[ __ ] people man once you start
going down the rabbit holes of this
white supremacy stuff like right they
present you know oh we're hardcore
christian you know no abortion
there's a bunch of like satanists in
there too
there's there's all sorts of crazy [ __ ]
going on they're all coming together to
try to like overthrow democracy it's and
this is part of that ruse is is what
you're yeah
well someone's got to fund it you know
yeah right well and and someone has to
make that appearance right and they
[ __ ] they this who's the richest man in
the world do you know do i know yeah
who's the richest man in the world right
now well uh is it is it not jeff bezos
who who's the richest man in the world
vladimir putin most likely okay well
that is like
you're saying like based on undisclosed
holdings yeah you mean i mean like that
the holdings that he would control is
what you're saying yes yeah right and
and uh who better to launder a bunch of
money into legitimate systems
so he can pay people and buy things and
you know buy politicians in an attempt
to overthrow democracy you know i
remember uh
one of us saying something uh just a bit
ago about all rhodes and putin something
like that i don't remember yeah yeah
well okay so so like if you look at
austria uh their former
uh prime minister a guy named kurtz
right uh he had to quit he resigned he's
he's under investigation for
uh
i forget
exactly what it was but it's corruption
basically right
he's going to work for peter thiel he
went from austria to silicon valley
uh and he's a corrupt politician oh [ __ ]
nobody saw that coming christ yeah um
and then you look at like a former
german chancellor is now working for
putin at gazprom like he's buying all
these rich [ __ ] and they're
just bending over and taking it because
they want to stay rich and it's anyway
more sniff tests okay let's let's let's
take a big whiff of this this horseshoe
big stinky whiff of this right oh yeah
that smells good
seven donations seven names one email
address seven different zip codes
five canada two us one yes
this is good i was gonna say maybe at
the end of the day there's a whole
business model we don't know about maybe
there's like co-sharing of emails
yes this seems to be a [ __ ] pattern
here really honestly but email sharing
wow what an ex
you've hit on something um the the
reason i you see that yellowish column
there
that's the that's the date time stamp
right
and and what you see so timestamp of
like when the transaction was made right
when the transaction was made okay right
so you've got one at 5 48 on the 7th and
then you've got one uh 20 minutes later
and then you've got one almost two hours
later but then one
two minutes after it
and then one four minutes after that and
then one five minutes after that and
that one six minutes after that
so this email was like busy this email
was [ __ ] busy yeah
and all the names are different it's you
know is you i covered this up i don't
want to dox anybody i'm not one of those
reporters like look at this [ __ ]
right right i'm not i'm not like that
because it's really it really is it may
not even be that these people even know
this right i mean yeah there's a
possibility right it's very possible
that the people whose credit cards were
used
have no [ __ ] clue i have no idea and
and the question of like will they even
know like you know how closely do people
you know some people are very diligent
about you know making sure that things
balance out in their their transactions
but other people are kind of like yeah i
charge it whatever and and especially if
it's smaller transactions you might
not even kind of question it yeah you
wouldn't even notice right yeah i i i
spent five bucks and i'm like yeah
whatever five bucks i put on my bank
card i don't care so what what's the
amount of these transactions then
speaking of that what's the 50 90 200
125 20
uh
72 50 and 60. so nothing that may ring a
big alarm bell on someone's credit card
bill i mean maybe maybe depending on
like your balance and how much you spend
monthly if you use it like on a monthly
basis but nothing huge like two thousand
or five thousand dollars like you know
under 200 bucks uh at least yeah yeah
yeah you know it's it's a could be but
what's what's [ __ ] up is it's two
different types of cards they're
and these are in order there's a
mastercard credit a visa credit a visa
credit card credit
you know the same but they're all using
that same freaking email right with a
different
different name
yeah yeah right yeah
so so because but but you but going back
to because that that that brings up such
a good point because going back to what
we were talking about earlier when
you're entering your [ __ ] credit card
information into a into a payment
processor if your [ __ ] zip code isn't
the correct for that card number it's
not going to process that card so by us
by knowing that each one of these zip
codes are different
you you almost automatically know that
each one of those card numbers have to
be [ __ ] different because the payment
processor and its automation wouldn't i
mean i guess it could glitch but it
wouldn't necessarily process that
payment if the [ __ ] card number and
the goddamn zip code don't match right
right
i'm just saying but but but the only
contact the reporters have is that email
address and it's all the same email
address so if i like to you know if i
want to contact all those different
people i'm sending
one email so that that that actually
maybe we can invent a product here right
here on the air
why couldn't you have a contact type
software that you know absolutely had to
be like a token kind of thing for any
kind of transaction where it has the
appropriate uh identification for the
contact information
um
for the question also so what you're
saying is what you what what you are
referring to is something called
two-factor authentication okay and that
does exist but banks
have not integrated that into card
transactions online and maybe they
[ __ ] should well i mean this might be
this this this way if this is money
laundering if they are laundering money
through this ruse um by having these
fake transactions well i mean they're
real transactions because it's actual
money right it just yeah the guy real
transactions right but
i i think it's it's hacked or
compromised cards all right so the next
one eight donations eight names eight
zip codes
one email address
750 bucks
it doesn't oh and also you know i
noticed in this one uh it's got the same
translation errors that we saw earlier
right right and then i feel like this
whole like this whole presentation just
needs to be either like prepended with
the cardi b like that's suspicious
because that's what this is that is the
constant theme throughout this whole
thing like each time a new site comes up
i'm like what the [ __ ] is i just i
should
every slide should have this emoji
[Music]
why i mean i mean realistically
the thing that really pisses me off here
is that we're supposed to believe that
this is that this trucker thing is
supposed to be the thing that's gonna
change freedom and all this [ __ ] right
and here we are at the at the nuts and
bolts of
money in money out because that's what
they always say follow the money right
they always say that's always how you
get that's how law enforcement agencies
end up finding these [ __ ] is
follow the money here we are and it's so
easy to see right in plain sight that
something's [ __ ] up right there's but
if you look at all the articles about it
it's not about following in the money
it's about harassing the people who
[ __ ] donate like i don't really [ __ ]
what you donate to right i'm saying
these donations don't look right right
they're not real i mean they don't look
real right yeah they don't they don't
look normal i mean really and like we
were saying earlier maybe those high
donations were also a ruse to make sure
that if something were happened
that someone could you know be pointed
out that look look over here while
they're you know distracting
make that donation right to make sure
hi-fi isn't going through the data to to
have [ __ ] emails and [ __ ] they're
pointing at the point for the media to
point at uh benjamin pogue in texas
who's the ceo of of a [ __ ]
construction company where his dad used
to run it and started it and was
pardoned by none other than donald trump
for tax fraud which seems significant
but you know oh gee
yeah go figure all right all right take
a deep breath man this is this is the
last big huge sniff right here oh here
we go 16 donations 15 names 16 different
zip codes eight in canada eight in the
u.s over a thousand dollars in donations
all to one single email address
and
and still got that random character
translation errors and then you look at
the credit card types right
two were american express
six
six were visa credit cards
three of them were visa debit cards and
four of them were mastercard credit
cards but all the same same email what
the [ __ ]
that's
and okay you see that thing that column
in red donation date look at those time
stamps 508 509 510 510 516.
i mean this email was like
yeah there's no way that you that any
human unless you've got multiple
computers or multiple tabs open ready to
just execute the
donation
would ever be able to do this or or even
if it's how many how many transactions
16 16 different humans trying to use the
same email trying to coordinate this
thing at the same time have you ever
tried to get someone to [ __ ] venmo
you money i mean come on
you're like dude did you send it no i
mean yeah it's so [ __ ] easy the cash
it's the cash at man just [ __ ] send
it you know i can see matt gatts you
know trying to [ __ ] send the venmo
for drugs and hookers and and you know
it takes a little bit it takes a little
bit this coordinates for catering
catering bro oh yeah yeah sorry i'm
sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry
ice cream you're right you're right
right right right sandwiches right yeah
but yeah if there isn't any bigger of
like an eyebrow raise it would be right
here
i mean this is insane
and again that random character
translation [ __ ] going on that is a
scripting problem that is a character
trans
i think something's [ __ ] automated i
really do
but you're what you're saying is the
transactions are possibly being um the
the automation is coming from creating
the transactions through that back door
that we were talking about earlier is
that what you're saying i'm saying it's
probably coming through some sort of
back door or maybe they're what you can
do you can write a computer program and
you can have a file of just names and
credit cards you can have a file of
quotes
you can have a file of dollar amounts
right and just randomly grab this line
grab one line from this file grab one
line from this file grab one line from
this file stick it in the database so
what you're saying is is that maybe the
script that they wrote is [ __ ] it up
and they're pulling the wrong one or not
pulling the whole thing
exactly okay or they didn't pull
multiple addresses when they should have
or maybe they didn't have enough
addresses that people would respond to
so they had to double up on them right
or in this case 16 up on them okay
so that that was you know i was just
going through looking at some of these
duplicates see what it looked like that
looked crazy as [ __ ] just try to smell
what you're stepping in right yeah yeah
so what i wanted to do was disprove my
theory like okay i've got all these
duplicates i
seem [ __ ] fake
are there duplicates that seem real and
so i went you know do legitimate
donations exist yes they do okay
and then utilizing you know this first
name last name
zip code i was able to locate some
individuals i did you know i reached out
to them for comment none of them wanted
to comment for some reason go figure
nobody nobody responded at all no did
anyone say like no comment or would you
just silence just just silence no no
email back no telephone call back
um
well here remember this one the the two
five thousand dollar right
right um i found this guy
and he is the president of a company
that sells uh
firearm sites to the marine corps
and the united states special operations
command
okay that seems significant
you think
okay
yeah and so then i kept looking and i
looked at another one with duplicates
and i found a tarot reader from seattle
she made four donations of five dollars
a piece with 20 bucks
found her linkedin founder twitter
however what i found really weird about
this one
uh i found a podcast i listened to a
couple episodes of her podcast it had a
bunch of that i am theosophy cult that
mike flynn was doing that spiritually
[ __ ] tied together what the [ __ ]
but here's where it gets really funny
deep in this thing queuing is even deep
in this thing okay i went down into her
podcast and i was just i was kind of
flipping through the
the labels i found this one over here on
the far far top right our collective
vision quest with a couple other people
and this name only andre olar and i'm
like wow what a [ __ ] name right
so i looked the guy up
and yeah he's on youtube he's this
astrologer
okay next but but the next result for
him was only andre olar
from cluj's romania who has a background
in editing data analytics um operations
god oh okay he was a community manager
just running social media no big deal
you know just running ops yeah
what the [ __ ]
i mean if you know anything about the
history of the internet research agency
and how they did all their troll ops and
[ __ ]
yeah
um this one seems kind of funky as [ __ ]
yeah and i was just i was just looking
at the woman just like kind of trying to
figure out who this is
right
um and i just found this and i'm like
holy wow
holy cow i think they would be better
about it but okay dude they're so bad at
this so bad yeah
and i found a third individual okay
multiple multiple donations uh hundred
dollars a piece 400
400
this guy is an information architect
for canada border services agency
what what okay explain that for a second
did you go back what does that mean
exactly
canada border services agency are the
people
who take care of the border like the
ambassador bridge so you mean you mean
like you mean like
maybe an important bridge that someone
would want to clog up to stop you know
commerce from coming across it possibly
to to you know maybe like
uh
act like you had a protest for something
specific maybe a vaccine or or a mandate
or something like that is that what
you're saying
yeah okay
okay someone who might know like what
the important border crossings are
between america and canada someone who
happens to just know the logistics of a
country right
how you would clog such a bridge right
and and someone who's obviously a very
intelligent individual you don't become
an information architect or what is it
what is an information aren't you think
what is what does that mean well
depending on how they use the name an
information architect could be someone
who designs how data is laid out in
databases wait wait so you mean like
like maybe they would know a backdoor or
something possibly for this you know i'm
just saying as many technology people as
i've seen in this thing
[Music]
yeah yeah okay yeah
um and actually that brings us to our
next person
uh this guy's a recruiter
and
and i've got it it gets better
it gets better uh i found this person
and i found records for this person for
this the name used in this email
uh this person appears in government
american government records
uh in 2017 wait wait is like an employee
or a contractor as an employee okay
uh yeah as an employee of the united
states department of commerce
now
under trump the department of commerce
was run by a fellow named wilbur ross
yeah i remember that guy he he couldn't
hardly stay awake because you know i
don't know if he's if he's tired or he's
old i can i think he's a zombie i'm not
sure what that might be it might be yeah
uh but something interesting about
wilbur ross is before he became our
secretary of commerce
he was on the board of the bank of
cyprus if you know anything about cyprus
that's one of the biggest money
laundering centers right i think we're
going to find more about cyprus in the
years to come but yeah
yeah
yeah um
okay so i looked this guy up and i i
looked in the zip code and i couldn't
find
that name that full name other than the
government records but what i did find
was the middle name and the last name of
an individual who worked at palantir
okay so remind the audience why that's
significant
palantir is peter teals
data company this that [ __ ] guy yeah
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] guy okay yeah
gotcha and then and then supposedly
supposedly
at the time he was working for the
government for wilbur ross
he also worked at this company called
convoy plus i think if you're i don't
know if you're allowed to work two jobs
when you work for the government so that
might be something worth looking at
might be a conflict of interest yeah
well maybe
yeah and now now he's working at a
company called andrill uh which is
making assassination drones that they
want to put a.i in what the [ __ ] oh and
so we got some black mirror [ __ ]
happening here
black mirror [ __ ] going on but here's
the funny part of this uh anderl is
palmer lucky who got a shitload of money
for oculus from uh mark zuckerberg right
um
uh
oculus so wait wait wait wait wait wait
a second wait a second what do you think
virtual reality all right right
now that name is significant in a matt
gats case
the name is very significant in a matt
gatsby oh yeah
yeah uh palmer lucky um
i'm not sure but it kind of seems like
he sold his sister to roger stone and
met geis
right and and uh right and because that
name comes up in the joel greenberg case
when you said i get like wait a second i
i remember that um because
um there's that person uh again appears
into some of the now rather it will
become anything inside that federal
prosecution but that name does appear in
that story
go ahead sorry sorry i didn't mean to
stop the momentum no no no worries no
worries uh another person who works at
anderle is a guy named chuck johnson
and uh chuck johnson went with dana
rohrbacher uh to offer julius julian
assange a pardon now wait a second uh
because oh and he works for peter thiel
right well right of course
who doesn't at this point to dana
dana there he he is a uh
he was in congress correct
dana rohrabacher yeah that was uh that
was the one kevin mccarthy said i think
there's two people uh putin pays
dana rohrabacher and trump okay so so
so because dana rohrbacher is a huge i
mean he basically wears putin putin knee
pads like this [ __ ] yes like like we
think we think ron johnson and some of
these other sycophants that are
propagating this rand paul some of these
other [ __ ] that are propagating this
russian [ __ ] um for them and for putin
dana rohrbacher makes make these people
look like [ __ ] prudes
to the [ __ ] that he is for putin i mean
let's be by the way
you know who interned with dana
rohrabacher who is that who is that
eric prince oh well who is eric prince
who is this guy wow that you speak of
everyone probably knows who eric prince
princes but who is eric prince well uh
your your former uh your former guest
stewart rhodes kid knows who eric prince
is right he's right one of the people in
the chain of command above stuart rhodes
mike flynn and eric prince eric prince
uh well he's betsy the voss's brother
right that's significant
that's significant uh he ran a company
called blackwater that was responsible
for
murdering a bunch of afghanis in a
massacre i mean maybe maybe maybe he
would have some interest in [ __ ]
death drones that you say i i you know
i'm just maybe yeah i'm just snowballing
here uh
eric prince is in trouble uh he's in
trouble because he trained the project
veritas people to try and get them to
spy on rnc members and democrats
um
he may be involved in the theft of uh
biden's daughter's diary
right i don't know that for sure right
um
it seems suspicious though
eric prince is a shady son of a [ __ ]
and uh yeah he violates sanctions he's
been attached you know he's been
attached to multiple
uh surveillance ops for authoritarians
um
he has been involved
there is chatter that he has been
involved in overthrowing governments he
was actually he this eric prince was
working in myanmar
right before the coup
with a chinese company
and selling surveillance equipment and
software and [ __ ] to the myanmar
military and then all of a sudden the
myanmar military
overthrows the government so go for it
nice so is there anyone else that works
for this andrew that we should know
about or is connected to this andrew
uh general tata who's a friend of
michael flinch
of course
why was that listen you're making it
difficult here and the reason why is
because i have to tag all these
[ __ ] in the youtube video and
the list is getting very [ __ ] long
here of all these [ __ ] characters
that are playing out in this story it it
it really is becoming it's like i said
it's supposed to
tell this story it's hard to tell this
story because there are so many facets
of this right yeah do you think that's
intentional absolutely like their like
their their idea of layering this like a
[ __ ] onion is that it is so hard to
peel it back before you just get you
know just get frustrated and start
crying and just walk away from the
[ __ ] onion when the average american
considers seinfeld reruns to be far too
high brow
something like what the [ __ ] i like
seinfeld reruns i like well
yeah but there are some people like
seinfeld used to he's too intellectual i
can't watch that no uh give me real
housewives yeah right right uh so a
story like this is very difficult to
tell people because
they're so yeah
it's like an ogre it has layers right
so one of one of the other things i
looked at um and this can be confirmed
by other data scientists but one of the
things i looked at is
how many donations of a certain dollar
amount
went through gibson go for this for this
uh
fundraiser and as you can see
now in in a general fundraiser
you know you see a lot of
uh you know if we're looking at this
left or right you would see a lot of
smaller donations
and then as the dollar number got bigger
you would see it coming down
to the right
that's not what we see we see this we
see this huge hump
up to 100 and and those those big blue
lines are like 5 10 15 20 25.
uh there's a 40 one there's a 50
the biggest the second biggest is 50
the biggest is 100 right
but then as you go along this screen
there's bumps at like 250
400
300 500
a thousand
like who is
bumping
yeah it does not seem like an organic
distribution of donations but what i did
do was i broke it out because this seems
like a really weird distribution right
so i broke it out by credit card
thinking that like maybe one of the
cards had something no if you look at
every single credit card
every single one has that same
distribution pattern you mean you mean
the type of credit card so like you're
we're seeing here american express
discover like when you broke them up
when you broke them up into those
categories that's when you seen the same
type of pattern same type of like what
you see is you see that big spike in a
hundred on all of them
right
and then you see a spike just to the
left that's the 50.
and then you see a spike to the right
that's generally uh 150. but wouldn't
you see it on every single car but
wouldn't it wouldn't it make sense
though if if like
like if you were gonna go donate you
know to a donation site and it was like
hey
here's this amount you can donate this
amount you can donate this amount you
can donate this amount you can donate
this amount click these buttons here to
make it easy or you can enter in your
own like uh amount like wouldn't that i
said
let's say they had a 100 button no 100
button that would make sense and i kind
of remember them having buttons but i
don't remember a 500 button and if you
look at that visa one of those big
spikes is the 500 amount right so that
doesn't seem legit to me and and here's
the other thing if you see over there
all the way on the right there
uh that says blank
how do you have donations with
blank credit card info
yeah now wait a second
you're saying that there's actual
transactions with the um an amount of
money that was transferred there's an
actual transaction but there's no number
for the transaction no there is i think
what it says is there is a number but
there's no credit card company or a
credit card platform there's no credit
card system that is associated with it
oh
so the money the money got charged so
basically what you're saying is though
is that there are transactions on here
in in basic terms
that are transactions they have numbers
they have zip codes they have the email
address but we don't know
what credit card that they come from
like a visa no
type no brand no
nothing and i
uh unless your data is being
manipulated or corrupted i would not
expect to see that so how many
transactions are in that category uh i i
don't know i'd have to go back and look
at my data i can't even
not a huge amount not a huge amount not
enough to be too suspicious right well
it was it was statistically relevant
like you look at that and you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on there uh
another thing i found is prepaid credit
cards and and there's a type of money
laundering called structuring
uh and structuring is you get a bunch of
prepaid credit cards like you pay cash
for them or you get them some way is
this kind of like is this kind of like a
gift card but it's got the visa or
mastercard thing on it exactly where you
can use it anywhere essentially yeah
yeah it's a prepaid
fake
not fake but it's a prepaid card
it's not attached to a bank account or
anything like that right right right
uh but i did the numbers on the prepaid
and the blank the dollar amounts
and it's over a hundred grand holy [ __ ]
yeah so that so the prepaid cards is a
hundred grand got dumped into this thing
yeah just just prepaid a loan well okay
so prepaid alone was 68 643 blank and
this is what i said it was statistically
relevant
it's 39 000. that's where it adds up
yeah
and between those two that's 108 grand
right there and you can see the breakout
on the left
and uh yeah it seems seems a bit odd
that somebody also would use a pre-paid
card right like they wouldn't just use
the original source of the transaction
well i mean so these prepaid cards
though you can keep loading money on
that right like is that the kind of
prepaid card you're talking about like
you can keep loading money onto the same
card or
i do not know
all i know is that
what you see is those row labels there
american express credit prepaid diners
diners club who the [ __ ] yeah that's a i
haven't seen diners club since like an
infomercial
oh yeah
discovered credit
oh that we're going to talk about that
jcb one in a minute uh mastercard
right
well yeah
yeah
and here's what's really really
really weird about that
there are only four donations on jcb
cards
5 15 20
100.
i think that was a test run
i think they
slid those through those four little
donations they slid them through to make
sure they could get money through that
japanese bank and here's the other thing
it's not like our uh our youtube diving
video guy
is the one that made these either
because he had different ones he didn't
even have any jcb yeah these these were
not attached to the to that japanese
email address
yeah buddy
so anyway here's my conclusion okay
highly advanced mix of both possibly
scripted fake and
legitimate donation behaviors
this is just a cursory intervent
investing you know this is me one guy
doing this right
um
but i think this warrants
heavy duty investigation from the feds
uh you know and because it's across
borders because it's between canada and
america you're going to need fincen
you're going to need finchac
rcmp maybe secret service uh definitely
department of justice because they're
big on the money laundering there's one
supposed to be doing this
um
and
this
this fundraiser specifically
but also give send go as an organization
in general and that's that's why one of
the things i'm doing is i'm trying to
find you know trying to get a hold of
these other
uh fundraiser data sets to see if i can
find the same kind of behaviors that we
saw in this presentation
in those
uh in those data sets and and you're
talking about the data sets for example
the written house give go the written
house the proud boys going to dc the
proud boys buying
uh body armor the proud boys
you know they're raising money on gibson
go right now
for january 6th defendants right right
the
the quote-unquote as marjorie
taylor-green
and matt gatswood call them and donald
trump for that matter the political
prisoners because it seems like they
fear of being a political prisoner
possibly i'm just saying yeah and the
fact that you have a website like gifts
and go who has now i mean like if you
look at all these different events
and the types of people associated with
them
have now said yeah we're cool being
affiliated with every single one of them
right the fact that they have now
established themselves as the place to
go if you want to overthrow
or you want to fund some sort of
extremist group
come to our christian site right like
christian right right i mean i put in
quotes yeah
actually how i reported them uh was i
called up the phone numbers uh for the
rcmp and for the secret service uh for
terrorist financing so as as far as
because you said proud boys several
times there um and this is their
favorite
um
uh
way to collect funds as in a gofundme
type of way right because gofundme is
probably pro gofundme is like the most
popular you know uh run-of-the-mill one
right i mean i i've never done these
things so
um if if you're gonna if you're gonna
slide under the radar right online
fundraising is a great way to go because
there aren't really
enough
regulations in place to stop
if i'm right to stop what i want you're
talking about internet crowd sourcing so
what are the ways would you would you
work your way into donating other than
what you're talking about internet
crowdsourcing um what other ways
wouldn't be as easy to get away with
would not be as easy right mm-hmm
uh
wow i mean sending people checks would
be really hard because you have a paper
trail right right um i can tell you a
way that's actually easier
okay there is a way that's easier
crypto
okay right which they didn't they really
they started to use they're they're
going to crypto now yeah yeah
yeah and uh
you know government
let me ask you let me ask you about some
of the names we talked about earlier and
you say crypto is there any of those
names any of those names we mentioned
earlier that would have any i'm just i'm
just snowballing her
i don't know this for sure i'm just i'm
making up [ __ ] here right like this idea
that crypto could enter the chat is any
of those names that we talked about
earlier that i have to go through and
tag them on this uh youtube video to
make sure people can find them is there
anyone specifically that might be tied
to any kind of cryptic
um
specifically
no okay but but
and it's a big one probably
well it's it's a big one peter thiel uh
here we go
thing called the intellectual dark web
which is
queueing on for rich folks basically
is this is this the whole they're gonna
go to mars thing or they're gonna create
islands or some [ __ ]
well that was his seasteading project oh
okay basically basically peter thiel
does not like being part of a collective
and playing by rules right right and
unfortunately we live in a collective
and there have to be rules because if
there weren't rules we just have
freaking anarchy right and
at the end of the day
i i am
all for anarchy
but
people are not smart enough for anarchy
yet they can't control themselves
they're violent they're sexual sexually
deviant they're they're nuts
right right the only way we're gonna
have a functioning
anarchistic society is if people get a
shitload smarter and stop acting like
primates
right um and i know that's not going to
happen
it's hard once you've radicalized a
group of people you know to then stop
and question and say oh this is not just
not just radicalize them but think about
what the right has been doing to our
educational system for the last 50 years
right or even recently right well i mean
recently there was there was a
and i don't know who she is but there
was a clip
the of the woman on tucker carlson she's
supposed to be some kind of firearms
trainer or some [ __ ] she's talking about
homeschooling children and she's
basically saying we can't trust the
school system to teach
our children right-ring propaganda so
what you must do is to bring them in
your home and teach i mean she didn't
say in so many [ __ ] words she's
trying to placate to even the leftist
have you noticed how the right wing has
almost appropriated some of the leftist
you know terms and the leftist way of
saying things like like for instance
they want to ban they want a band to
kill a mockingbird because it has the n
word in it right that was always this
this left with they're they're
appropriating these reasons
right the ends to a mean like we were
talking earlier it's almost like it's a
ruse to make sure or like a testing tank
the thing like if you were gonna have i
don't know like supposedly a protest
against vaccines say and then you would
have a crowdsourcing thing where i don't
know like maybe you would have a ruse
where you would test to see how you
would raise funds and launder money
through this i'm just i'm just making up
stuff here again
make sure right right
radical probably pulling it straight out
of my ass no evidence whatsoever
i mean if if you if you really wanted to
cause chaos in the streets of the united
states maybe you would do something like
get a bunch of
white
theocratic fascists western chauvinists
and then you'd get a bunch of
antifa types leftists
and you'd wind both sides up and you'd
let them loose in the street and say oh
my gosh look how
much of a failure your society is look
at these people fighting in the streets
look how democracy sucks in other words
look how democracy sucks oh my goodness
um
well don't get me wrong there are
probably people on both sides who are
legitimate who are truly organic who
feel that way but i also have the
feeling that there are people on both
sides
who are paid to wind [ __ ] up right well
so when we uh you you brought up dakota
adams stewart rhodes is a strange son
and um he he has alluded to the fact
several times and the court documents
even show this too
that um the qrf or stewart rhodes and
the oath keepers were possibly waiting
for something to
uh some chaos to ensue rather that would
be black lives matter or antifa where
violence would break out um and then the
eastman memo and the powerpoint for the
the plan for the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup was basically to
uh use that
violence and chaos in a way to
enact the insurrection act and use
martial law to deputize possibly a group
like the oath keepers to then maybe
arrest members of congress that they
wanted to arrest to possibly you know
maybe maybe not maybe even the vice
president himself i don't know mike
pence maybe that's why the guy didn't
get into the [ __ ] secret secret
service car i don't know i'm just saying
that what it sounds like what you're
saying has already been tested like
where there's already been a pre-show to
what they want right yeah uh it's called
portland anyway um
right well well i mean i mean portland
the kyle i mean don't you think the kyle
rittenhouse trial it wasn't about kyle
rittenhouse and the event that happened
right it was about what they could do
with the trial when if he was convicted
or if he was not convicted right they
wanted so bad for [ __ ] violence to to
break out after written house was
again rather he was found guilty or not
guilty i don't think they really gave a
[ __ ] they didn't care if that that
[ __ ] went to prison or he didn't
they didn't give a [ __ ] what the result
was the only result they cared about was
that there was violence and chaos
because of whatever the [ __ ] result
was right no there were two things they
wanted out of that okay
all right one was violence and chaos yes
you're absolutely correct
uh the second
was for ellen wood
to
get the [ __ ] bail money back okay so
here we go you're adding another person
to my tag list here
ellen wood
yeah
does this does this have anything to do
with the gifts and go and the bail money
and him getting it back what what does
that have to do with what we're talking
about with this data set here and
possibly comparing it to like the
written house gibson go what is what
does he have to do in getting the bail
money back what does that have to do
with it
if
you want soldiers to fight a war be it
physical
be it
digital
digital soldiers
you got to pay them right
so you're going to run ops if you don't
have money for ops right right
you're you're saying people's loyalty
and their bank accounts go hand in hand
i believe so yeah i i feel you i feel
you so so gabe do you have any um more
questions here for hi-fi on this on this
uh
i mean okay yeah i'm just like what the
[ __ ]
i know but no it's honestly like
you know it comes as no surprise that
obviously these people are
in some way associated with the events
and
uh the actions that have been taken
behind this like
movement right um so that is not that's
like a
we've seen aspects of this kind of play
out and be tested and then try a little
bit of a larger test right now to what
they hope to be
larger uh
kind of events that happen in the us or
in other countries or whatever i mean
god damn there's so much [ __ ] in this
powerpoint that i'm like [ __ ] it is one
of those things where you would never
imagine yourselves living through or at
least
seen something
happen again
that we've seen previously happen right
so especially right now it's on a
obviously a digital financial side where
we're finding ways to
legally launder money to fund extremist
groups
um for your own
political ploy whatever it might be i i
you ever listened to run the jewels
oh yeah rtj i love them and and here we
are
uh
the same moment in history back to haunt
us
you know
that's that's what we're facing we're
we're facing a group of i mean if you
look up there's a guy named smedley
butler what if here you
okay
smedley butler testified in front of
congress that a bunch of big rich
hoity-toity [ __ ] businessman
had a plan to overthrow franklin delano
roosevelt
right
nothing ever really came of that
right
but that's what we're looking at we're
looking at you know we're looking at
corporate oligarchs joining with
literal fascists like vladimir putin
uh mobsters like his oligarchs
um
white supremacists
and they're trying to overthrow liberal
democracy not just in america
right but around the world right and
trying to use it by seeping into
people's minds because i think that's
the overall the overall story here
because you said earlier that it's a
very complicated story and i and i
always try to make things i always try
to make things as simple as i possibly
can and in language that everyone can
understand i think i could do that i
think that's i think that's maybe
possibly my signature is basically what
yeah
ready
rich [ __ ] are trying to take
over everything and crush you like a bug
get up and fight back that's it well and
and and i think i think that is um that
is perfect and the reason why is because
they're using this idea to seep into
minds of people who wouldn't normally
think this way that democracy bad right
democracy is bad then the alternative
must be good because you know this idea
that democracy bad and if democracy's
bad then the alternative must be good
because dum-dums do dumb things right
and they think dumb ways and i'm not
saying people aren't intelligent or
educated it's just so much easier to to
have everything in black and white i
mean you know we scrolled through social
media so fast and everything happened so
fast and we're so worried about tom
brady retiring and how [ __ ] deflated
the ball actually is right so it's so
democracy bad the alternative must be
good because and and that is the [ __ ]
thing that they're trying to seep into
people's minds and anyone who can hear
me out there that is pro-democracy
that understands that look democracy may
not be perfect and democracy is [ __ ]
really [ __ ] hard and it's going to
continue to be hard it won't ever be
[ __ ] easy it's like inch by inch
millimeter by millimeter but it's all
[ __ ] worth the work and the reason
why is because if you really want
liberty true liberty not freedom not
rights because rights and freedoms
deliver us our liberty right our liberty
is what we strive for if that's really
what you're looking for if that's really
what you think you want to have the
democracy is the best tool to deliver
that it's the hardest it takes the
longest it is a work of art in other
words you got to put a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] into it to make it look beautiful
and we're going to have to continue
because the alternative though if
democracy bad the alternative must be
good the alternative is authoritarianism
totalitarianism how [ __ ] easy is it
to pick out one [ __ ] and say you
get to make all the decisions and i have
to live with the consequences right
that's not [ __ ] liberty that's not
[ __ ] freedom that's not [ __ ] right
that's [ __ ] fascism and i think
that's what that's what they're trying
to do
is psyop whatever you want to call it
they're trying to use all kinds of means
necessary whether it be social media
rather it be these [ __ ] [ __ ]
protests these [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] things by duping by duping
dum-dums into believing that this [ __ ]
is real because i cuz we me and me and
gabe have talked to several people that
were there on the [ __ ] capitol on on
january 6. and people have said outside
on the lawn on on the grass people were
[ __ ] partying they were like sitting
on coolers drinking beer that's the
feeling you got up towards the capitol
it was a little different inside was
completely [ __ ] different and i
believe that a lot of those people went
there
that that went to the [ __ ] rally
didn't go to the [ __ ] capital there
was people who went to the rally who
went to the capitol who weren't part of
this grand conspiracy they're the
[ __ ] dum-dums to make it look real
it's part of the [ __ ] ruse and
possibly some of the dum-dums that are
given to this stupid trucker thing in
ottawa through this
gibson go you're the [ __ ] dum-dums
you're the rubes that are making this
look [ __ ] real and and you're being
tricked into this stuff and and i i
don't want to i don't want to say that
these people
shouldn't have some kind of culpability
but at some point at some point
you know uh dum-dums do dumb things and
that's their ultimate goal is to
convince people democracy bad the
alternative has to be good
so
you know my first question is
everybody bitching about inflation how
the [ __ ] are you giving money away first
off right
um my second question
it's not a question actually it's it's a
statement is um you know what when we
interviewed the the president of estonia
and i looked into some of the history of
estonia when russia took over estonia
when authorities authoritarianism came
to town
they lined people up and shot them in
the back of the head
they raped women they raped children
they killed children
is that what you want for this country
because i sure as [ __ ] don't well and
we've we've said it a long time on on
this on this show is that when fascism
comes you're not gonna have you're not
gonna [ __ ] be talking about the nfl
you're not going to be talking about the
nba you're not going to be going to the
churches that you go to or the community
halls that you go to the job that you
have the companies that you work for
they won't be there they'll be different
because those things aren't what their
fascist state will that's not what their
fascist state will want they get to tell
you an authoritarian a totalitarian gets
to tell you what company you work for
they get to tell you what companies
exist what churches will exist who will
go to those [ __ ] churches and who
will not and and trust me when i say
this uh
we've had rachel bitkoff around here she
has a great phrase she calls them
breakfast narcs
your family will become breakfast snarks
everything will become uh the breakfast
snarks they will definitely definitely
come for you and it will not be fun and
it'll not be fun for you or your family
um no
uh gabriel i promise our brothers
another another run the jewels line i
promise our mothers they're coming for
you the day after they're coming for me
that's it gabe did you have any other
thing you'd like to add here at the end
on the whole uh democracy bad the other
thing good i mean we've seen it before
on a different scale which is when you
know which is a tactic that
[ __ ] hitler used which is when trump
would say this is fake news you can't
trust them this is fake news you can't
trust them but the source that you can
trust by default is me so anything i say
is true everyone else is false i'm good
they're bad i'm right they're wrong i'm
big they're small right because i'm the
alternate same thing same thing the the
the historical terms are
uh hitler used lugenpressa which is the
lying press the fake news right
now i agree that
media in general is manipulated by the
rich people who own it but you can kind
of see through that [ __ ] right yeah
um
the other
in general
the media does a decent job of reporting
facts
um you just have to keep in mind
everyone tries to sway you one way or
the other well we we know about fact
checkers here um yeah fact checkers are
important yeah well
they definitely are important when
someone sneaks into mar-a-lago and and
puts out fake statements right some
fact-checkers don't like me
they know you by name and that's why
they don't like you because they have to
know you by name
and the other the other historical thing
that uh trump
does
did is still doing is called grossa
lugen uh which is the big lie
right and we all know what the big lie
is i'm not even going to repeat it
because we know what it is right but if
you tell a lie big enough
people are going to believe it because
no one's ever going to believe no way
he's [ __ ] lying about that that's
right how could he lie about something
like that he was the president why would
he lie that's crazy right right well
except
he lies over through our government as
well right yeah and then there's still
people who believe that so it's crazy so
one last thing i want you to give a
shameless plug because i want you that
to plug because uh we've had heidi kudon
your co-host uh you have two other
co-hosts so plug plug plug some of your
uh your stuff here tell us where to find
all that and um
so that we the audience knows where to
find your guys's stuff uh so we are
radicalized truth survives podcast
um you can find
the podcast at radicalizepod on twitter
uh you can find heidi kuda at heidi
underscore cuda
one of our co-hosts sean is sean connor
2023
okay
jim
my other co-host and i uh
jim just recently got his first
suspension well it's actually his third
suspension but they're fighting this one
i have actually been suspended from
twitter 20 times oh well a record so
yeah radicalized truth survives you can
find us on youtube you can find us
radicalize pod on twitter
and uh we're just going to keep like
just fighting these people and doing
everything we can to tear their little
wannabe kingdoms apart because
[ __ ] we appreciate you joining us uh
thank you very go check out the um uh
podcast on youtube uh go follow the
podcast at radicalizepod on twitter and
follow all the hosts that are still on
twitter um and possibly we'll make it
back on twitter maybe eventually but
right now maybe maybe but right now go
follow the hosts that are on there we
appreciate you doing this stick around
we'll be right back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today droop be the
spread you want to see in the world
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking